[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
this is the third video about blockchain
on this channel and will most likely be
the final one in the series so again
this video is a collaboration between
the Dubai World Trade Center for their
future blockchain summit
so to recap in the first video around
six months are there we looked at
blockchains origins and how it had a
wider impact than just Bitcoin and in
the video last week we saw how it's
already starting to take hold in many
corners of business and commerce I think
will be beneficial to at least watch the
last video to get up to speed today
we'll be taking a look at the biggest
losers from the blockchain Revolution
number one middlemen when a technology
like blockchain or something similar is
mature basically anyone who profits from
the current clearing and settlement
mechanisms like those who process
paperwork and transfer ownership may
become a big loser
beyond this well-designed smart
contracts may cause risk to intermediary
organizations who provide clearing
settlement and ownership services for
profit supply chain managers may become
a loser when it comes to blockchain
tracking physical assets through changes
in ownership and handling can be
recorded and communicated through data
stored in the blockchain
this provides improved logistics
visibility important events within the
supply chain could be linked to
automatic payments through the use of
smart contracts blockchain also allows
for transactions to be time-stamped and
finalized with a mathematically proven
method for confirming any transaction as
valid according to the csiro of
Australia companies who oversee such
processes are at risk
david year mack professor of finance and
business transformation at NYU School of
Business sums up his views on blockchain
quite when you think of anyone who is
keeping track of assets I'd say that job
is very much at risk because of this
technology end quote
he goes on to say that the jobs at risk
include those involving tasks such as
processing transactions and verifying
documentation later glibness
a director at Safian global markets a
capital and commodities market
technology consultancy has a similar
view
the first area that will be hit would be
any reconciliation or post
reconciliation activities he just
wouldn't need it in quote in an
interview with the Financial Times she
does give a ray of hope quote I can see
a whole class of professions around
encryption and identity protection even
though some jobs will disappear we're
acquiring these we've never had before
around things more valuable than they've
ever been before end quote
number two banks sort of earlier on in
the proliferation of blockchain it was
thought that banks are going to be major
losers but now it seems that they're
taking blockchain in their stride
they're trying to become the disrupter
not to get disrupted this is being done
through the creation of private
blockchains which I admit I'm not
particularly thrilled about in September
of 2016
Barclays carried out the world's first
trade transaction using blockchain
they cut a process that normally takes
seven to ten days down to less than four
hours since then plenty of blockchain
banking projects have come up this
includes ibm's hyper ledger fabric the
utility settlement coin and r3 to name a
few in fact today around 80% of banks
are developing their own blockchain
technology in this environment of using
blockchain to facilitate transactions
individuals working in clearing houses
as well as stockbrokers may be under
threat if this trend continues in the
larger picture
banks will lose some business from those
who want to send money directly to each
other outside the traditional banking
system using crypto currencies so I
think it's a balance it seems like some
people in the financial sector will be
losers but there will be overall gains
within the sector number three they're
negligent everyday investor if you're
out to make a quick buck and blockchain
technology but you haven't done your
research you might be in for a nasty
surprise initial coin offerings or icos
are a new form of crowdfunding sort of
like a large-scale Kickstarter or
IndieGoGo campaign but for blockchain
and cryptocurrency applications due to
the lack of regulation ICO scams and
deceit are commonplace
the last major scam occurred in Vietnam
were in I see a claim that participants
could get a guaranteed 40 percent return
on their money monthly sound too good to
be true
well it was eventually the company
decided to run off with 660 million
dollars another case was the famous bit
connect scam saying so many people who
say that this was going to be a con
artists game that this was gonna be a
scam again hey you're gonna lose all
your money my wife still doesn't believe
in me like the Vietnamese I see a bit
Kinect guaranteed set returns on the
investment but this time from a
mysterious AI that traded the Bitcoin
market when the scam was revealed
hundreds of thousands of people lost a
whole bunch of money and some lost
everything
companies like this give a really bad
name to the blockchain investment space
so does this mean all ICS are bad no of
course not there are some great projects
out there but you just have to be
discerning you can think of it like the
IPOs during the dot-com era there are a
whole bunch of companies that are
raising a lot of money that didn't
really do all that much but the good
ones like Google and Amazon whether the
storm and actually became massively
profitable companies here are some tips
to stay safe
courtesy of medium one read the I see a
white paper thoroughly does the concept
make sense to you number two what
problem is the product solving does it
make business sense
number three study the team and their
experience dig into their history check
out LinkedIn profiles and previous jobs
number four check forums to gain insight
into what the cryptocurrency community
is saying about the project number five
take a look at what rating companies are
saying about the ICO if a new project
isn't rated there's a high chance that
it's a scam so almost at the end of the
video but I just wanted to touch on
something in the last video there's a
lot of people talking about the
environmental effects of the blockchain
mainly because of the excessive amount
of energy used
this is true in some cases but only for
certain types of blockchain like the one
that Bitcoin uses other newer block
chains use something called a proof of
stake method whereas Bitcoin uses a
proof-of-work method the proof of stake
method allows for far less energy
consumption and there's no monetary
incentive for mining so this means that
there's no holding of graphic cards
driving up the price that's just a
little note that I wanted to mention
thanks for watching that's the end of
this video I hope to be doing some live
streaming on this channel at the future
blockchain summit in Dubai this has been
to gogo you'll be watching cold fusion
and I'll see you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys have a good
cold fusion are you thinking
[Music]
you